what hahaha Jackson's Greg Alva here
with Lauren Francesca I want my Lauren
on everything
YouTube snap huh face Instagram Twitter
musically yeah the hell man you got
everything she's got everything I'm
gonna do a picture of the day shout-out
for Diego shy dad's at the end of this
video keep a lookout for that hey Lauren
yeah you ever heard of area 51 um yeah
it's like a military thing right yeah
I've been doing like aliens or some [ __ ]
do I believe in aliens yeah I do believe
in aliens I think you'll be very selfish
of us human beings to be like no we're
the only living race in all of the
galaxy so yeah I believe in it
this got sent over to us area 51 phone
call on a radio show are you ready for
this yeah I'm ready let's see if it's
spooky 1987 syndicated talk show what oh
wow mine it's also getting true with the
aliens it's definitely alien simply
alien the government wants everyone to
know about aliens that's what I've
learned from movies alright here we go
Sarge's they're here take your wattage
istic line you're on the air hello
boiler hi I don't have a whole lot of
time so let's begin
finding out whether you're using this
line properly or not very 51
were you an employer our unit I a former
employee was like I would let go on a
medical discharge about a week ago and
I've kind of been running across the
country and I don't know where to start
there they're gonna ill triangulate on
this position really really soon you
can't spend a long time ago so give us
some quick okay um um okay well what
we're thinking of as aliens art they're
they're they're extra dimensional beings
that an earlier precursor of the space
program made contact with they are not
what they claimed to be they have
infiltrated a lot of a lot of aspects of
military power particularly to area 51
disasters that are coming the military
and so the government knows about them
and there's a lot of safe areas in this
world that they could begin moving the
population to now are those during
another unit a or not they want the
major population centers white help few
left will be more easily controllable
desert
I should know
no that is crazy
there's three more minutes left
[Music]
three minutes of the transmission being
lost
so he spelled transmission
I thought it was two S's after the mi
[Music]
yeah don't worry guys
supers got it back on radio yeah
complain when they come in dating in
some way something knocked us off the
air and we're on a backup system now
government earth I don't know I don't
know well did you hear no you tell me
because you were listening
that was awful strange it was a really
weird guy on the air when it went off
yeah real weird out like going to sort
of sounding paranoid
yeah really like crying and everything -
yeah yeah and how far into conversation
was it when it went off and just a
couple about 15-20 seconds I'd say oh
you might hang guys missing are you
really meant to call them and I've got a
feeling somebody didn't want you to hear
it yeah because it was really strange
Olson I'm here in mark fuhrman where
will the network to the network of
course went immediately to a backup tape
while we trying to figure out what blew
up here so that's what you were to
happen and then we're down on a backup
link system that guy died on to be
linear
why I'm showing it in the air right now
you're on here right now well you better
be yes and where are you by the way I'm
in Michigan Michigan yeah I called the
other night and I wanted to ask two
things real quick I wanted to say one
thing and I want to ask another real
quick I want to ask if you can play that
remote viewing one when you earn while
you go to Egypt I'll discuss about like
area 51 if it's like the government's
trying to put it out there like that so
like some other places ins being watched
as much in other words it's a big decoy
to experiment thirdly we'll be back
after the news I think here money lost
all transmit capability on this end
we're here in operation ever before
Miller went belly-up suddenly for some
unknown reason I've never seen it do
this in all the years all the years that
we've been on the air I've never seen
the transmitter in this way this thing
will possibly fail a massive will fail
like a massive heart attack once we find
and so we've gone to a backup system
okay to get the signal to you right now
and I presume it is getting to you right
now yeah totally yeah the videos done do
you think it was real that guy with
that's how it seemed like he was coming
from a genuine place the question is is
he just one of those loonies who
believes in conspiracies like aliens oh
yeah I see entourage sir yeah exactly
because he didn't sound insincere he
sounded like he was being genuine but
that doesn't sincerity is not always
equate to truth right and how did all of
the transmissions get lost or whatever
how's that how does it happen you think
definitely we don't know anything I
don't know I mean I've called Loveline
many times and degeneres mission was
always perfect when I called oh that's
me talking about sex and relationship
questions that's not anything alien sex
alien from area 51 the aliens will have
sex when I'm not through it
I don't know what idea man
that does sound quite terrifying I mean
this is from the 90s okay now they're
talking about B they're gonna wipe out
population and it happened it ever it
didn't happen I really yeah like we just
don't realize it
imagine Oh ringing some crazy ground you
know what is that's what's what if we're
living amongst a bunch of alien invasion
a Body Snatchers kind of way like yeah
look like human I'm gonna get a headache
we have an assembly it could have been a
real I believe that aliens exist
I just hands I mean it's one of those
things where I believe it but whenever I
like
watch documentary or something like this
my skepticism does go pretty high as
what is this truth but I do believe that
they still exist I'm yet to come across
something rum like for sure aliens are
real uh-huh I don't know how could there
be only how come to see us humans in the
world of them the galaxy is huge there's
got to be like ILI's and other kind of
humans out in some other planet right
yeah right that time you know in an
alternate universe we believe in
parallel universes like there's not a
Greg out there
yes making youtube videos 100% gay yeah
yeah doing Beauty videos you're doing
fashion in he has a six-pack
she was a version of me I want to be in
this universe right man you believe in
parallel universes yes thank you
yeah what would you do if you met an
alien wanna make friends down so there
you go to EG scenario yeah so they don't
kill me or try to take my body I would
shock on the alien in the face really
mmm
what is there nothing is et showed up I
would have no it's et I'm gonna be like
oh he's a friendly yeah well if you're
watching I'm gonna shoot you in the face
yeah alien so threat of all baby boomer
[ __ ] out there there's been nothing
subscriber the real rejects get accepted
into the reject nation quick die
notification bill I want my Lauren
follow her on YouTube check out all her
social media she's actually just did
some videos of my brother jothika way
those videos we up
sometime this week keep a lookout for
that yeah we did a video too for her
channel that will go up soon hopefully
within a week or two yeah three weeks
yeah whatever
a patient of the day shadow Diego shy
dez de guiche i des he is a member of
our patient community now and there's a
photo here of him and oh that's him with
JK Simmons whoa whoa look at Diego yes
oh my god yeah handsome devil sexy guy
this ain't one of my like you know
homoerotic jokes he is just a flat-out
like I want to do things to him kind of
beautiful he's not your type of guy yeah
definitely
oh my god the skin like wrinkle-free
han smiles he's my lady whoa you're like
a perfect Mexican American I'm going to
assume you're Mexican usernames Diego
that's not racist that is uh that's just
pure racism I'm sorry but Diego my gosh
my friend I can keep the most beautiful
man whatever yeah I've been part of the
real rejects before nice nice to meet
you Diego I'm going to screenshot your
photo and look at it before I go to bed
tonight and I'm going to do an activity
that will help put me to sleep